This video is made possible
by Squarespace. Whether
you need a domain, website,
or online store,
make it with Squarespace.
Jack out squarespace.com for a free trial.
You'll also find a link
in the description below.
[inaudible] was a night he became
the richest man in all of France.
It became famous after battling alongside
Joan of arc and the name of God,
and he was well loved
by the French people.
No one could have imagined that just a
few years later he would be sentenced to
death for summoning a demon and murdering
over a hundred children for hundreds
of years.
He was considered to be one of the first
serial killers in recorded history.
However,
some modern day historians believe that
he was frames and they aren't trying to
exonerate him.
So did he really kill innocent children
as part of a satanic sacrifice or is he
one of the most misunderstood
figures in all of history?
Yeah,
shoulder when he was born in his
family castle, the Sham Tassa.
So law in 1405 when he was a
child shoulder raise parents,
they passed away and he was raised
by his grandfather. Jacques to crawl.
Gilles Ray was born during
the hundred years war,
which was a conflict between the
noble families of England and France.
It began in 1337 and ended in 1453 meaning
that the war went on for 116 years.
Multiple generations grew up in
nonstop warfare, kidnapping, death,
and torture just became
a part of normal life.
Considering how dangerous it wasn't that
time it became mandatory for all men in
noble families to be trained in
combat and warfare. At 16 years old,
children a rescued the Duke of Brittany
who had been kidnapped and taken
prisoner as a reward for saving the Duke.
The king awarded Jill Deray land grants
that allowed him to acquire massive
properties for free. Since he was 12
years old, Jill's grandfather, Joan,
was already trying to arrange
a marriage for the bike.
His first attempt was with a young heiress
who was only four years olds off to
trying and failing to arrange a
marriage for his grandson a few times.
Jolanda [inaudible] was able to broker
and agreements with the noble families
and Brittany.
Since Jill save that Duke's life when
he was in his early twenties [inaudible]
ray married Catherine to
through La Dochester Brittany.
She was the heiress to one of the biggest
fortunes in all of France back then.
Women could not own or handle money,
so estates were controlled
by fathers and husbands.
So as to the air of one of the biggest
fortunes in France from the deray family,
Marion Catherine Dubois made them one
of the richest couples in the entire
country.
Many everyone has heard
the story of Joe Navarro,
but it's important to remind you of
a tail because her feet shows so many
parallels to shield array.
The French city of only all had been
surrounded and captured by the English.
Joan of arc was just a 17 year old
peasant girl when she appeared before King
Charles the seventh and requested to use
his army to defeat the English and free
only on,
it's hard to imagine how such a young
woman without any Nobel status could have
had an audience with the king, let alone
get him to agree to handover and army.
But apparently she was very convincing.
Joan claimed that Michael the Archangel,
appeared to her in a vision
and that God was on his side.
She also claimed that she could
miraculously heal her wounds.
She demonstrated before the court even
the deepest wounds would heal with the
power of God.
She claims that he was helping her attain
supernatural powers in order to become
invincible.
Some documents actually claimed that the
king was actually terrified of Joan and
that he was practically forced to say yes.
Shoulder a was 25 years old at the time
he became the marshal of the army and
Joan Devoxx righthand
man in just nine days.
The two of them led the Ami to victory
for France and they became national
heroes and holy figures in society.
The fact that they fought in the name
of God and the Archangel Michael was
enough to reinvigorate French citizens,
Catholic faith, as you might imagine,
it was extremely humiliating for the
English to know that they were defeated by
a teenage girl when she
was just 19 years old.
Gen Ivanka was captured by the Bug
Indian party who agree with the French
nobleman spying for the English.
She was taken to court in England and
in 1431 she was burned at the stake for
witchcraft and memory lived on in the
hearts of the French people and she was
canonized as a saint
by the Catholic church.
The Burgundian party managed to kill up,
hasn't gone like Joan of arc,
but it was far more difficult to capture
a well-protected noble person like
shoulder ray.
He became the marshal of France and he
was even more rich and powerful and it
wasn't before because he also received
awards for winning the see Giovanni aunt.
He was also able to strike business deals
with other nobles who wanted to work
with him.
His court grew to be even more luxurious
than the king of France and the wealthy
leaders of the Catholic church. He decided
to retire from fighting. At this point,
he was still very young and had all the
money in the worlds to do essentially
whatever he wanted with.
Just like today when people get a
windfall of money at a very early age,
they sometimes make some stupid
decisions on how to spend it.
Sports cars and designer watches
hadn't been invented yet,
but he did invest in
several different estates.
Since this was investing in real estate,
his family found these kinds
of purchases to be acceptable,
but it started to get into too crazy.
When Jill deray began producing plays,
he spent a small fortune on theatrical
reenactments of his battles during the
hundred years war today,
producing multimillion dollar Broadway
plays and movies are completely normal
but mag. Then he was completely
unheard off his play,
how to vote 150 speaking roles and over
500 extras who acted as in the battle.
600 different costumes were commissioned
for the performance and Taylor's around
all the on while working
around the clock to make them.
He also gave his staff
and even the audience and
unlimited buffet of free food,
which pretty much guarantee that everyone
in town would show up to the formats
and his own way.
He was actually creating jobs and
making people happy by entertaining and
feeding the peasant class.
But from the perspective of his family,
this was horrifying.
Has inlaws is in Brittany,
spent multiple generations saving and
investing so that they had a family legacy
and it was sickening to them that this
young man was practically burning cash
and a garbage fire,
but of course it was yielder raise money
and he had every right to spend it.
However you wanted shoulder rate began
paying for his own personal chapel on his
estate.
This might seem strange,
but it wasn't actually that uncommon for
members of the European ability to have
their own church back in the day.
This way,
he could still attends mass and do
it from the comfort of his own home.
It was called Chapel of the holy
innocence named after a Vus in the book of
Matthew.
In this Vus,
King Herod orders a mass killing of
all children under two years old.
It's prevent a prophecy from coming true
that a child would grow up to overthrow
him. From a modern perspective, it
seems rather creepy. That shields array,
which wants a church named after a
story about the murder of thousands of
children. But some historians say
that it's exactly the opposite.
In the 14 hundreds the story actually
became popular among the French Catholic
community.
People when they hear a comparison to the
tragedy of these dying children in the
Bible to the hundred years war,
because the entire generations of people
who grew up without knowing a time of
peace, it was finally the coming
in vogue to be a pacifist.
By naming his personal church,
the chapel of the holy innocence,
he was actually making a political
statement that he wanted the hundred years
war to be over.
Considering that many of
the noble families profited
from constant warfare into
capturing territory's.
This was even more reason for
is in most to be angry with him.
The Duke of Brittany appears before the
pipe claiming that the shoulder ray had
an addiction to spending money.
He requested that the pope would deny
his application to have the chapel of the
innocence accepted as an official part
of the Catholic diocese that you coped.
There's a rejection would be enough to
stop childer ray from completing the
chapel,
but he went ahead and built it anyway,
even though his judge did not have a
real Catholic priests that to say mass
shoulder rate didn't let that stop him.
He has Taylor's custom meg lavish and
colorful costumes for him to wear and he
officiated mass himself.
This was considered to be extremely
blast from us since he was making it very
public statement that he knew that he had
just as much power as the king and the
Catholic Church and there was pretty
much nothing they could do to stop him.
His family met with the king asking
for a royal decree to stop anyone from
entering into a contract with Jill duray.
They claimed they were afraid he would
spend all of his money and that there
would be nothing left in his estate.
Thinking agreed to announced the Duke
of Brittany to take control over.
[inaudible] is a state that you have
Brittany making financial decisions on his
behalf and he completely cuts off
shoulder ray from all of his money often
looking over his financial records.
The Duke told Jill to ray that he had
spent everything he owns and that he was
now in debt, so therefore began
sending his properties one by one.
Lisa shoulder rate nuns.
There's one of his favorite castles
that the DEU could apparently sold,
was actually being gone by a
Catholic clergyman named Joel,
and if they're wrong and no one
was actually living there at all,
he was incredibly angry about this.
He wasn't going to stand for the Duke,
trying to make him both penniless and
homeless. He wanted to go back inside,
so he beats and kidnaps Jonah for wrong
in order to get the new keys to the
castle, get nothing, get a clergyman.
It was a very serious crime.
He did eventually let the man go,
but in the eyes of the Nobel community,
it was extremely shocking that
shoulder a would do such a thing.
It was becoming clear to
both the king and the pub.
The Jill [inaudible] was not
going to go down without a fight.
He was so powerful.
He could get away with just about
anything and stay out of jail.
The French people loved him for being
a hero and for his generosity to the
peasant classes if he wanted to. He even
have the ability to raise his own army.
This was a very scary thing for the powers
that be and they need to stop it now,
just before we get into the dark about
of this story where he apparently started
killing people,
I do want to tell you about today's
sponsor and I know they're having the
sponsor in the middle of the video
is not the most awesome thing,
but these videos are very long and
given the length that we put out,
I really hope you do appreciate the need
to put the sponsorships in the middle,
but I will keep it super brief.
Squarespace allows you to create
a powerful online presence,
whether that's from a personal side to
business or something else entirely.
It all starts on Squarespace with a
beautiful template that comes with the
requisite cool names
like pursuit and a rice.
You can either start from scratch or
easily move over an existing domain,
making everything super easy to manage.
I want to feel through these
super easy customization process.
There's no updates and patches,
none of that stuff you have to deal with
when you're making a website on another
platform. You know all that
super frustrating stuff. Look,
if you're looking to start a
business, pursue a dream, whatever,
just do it with Squarespace.
Head to squarespace.com for a free trial
and when you're ready to go launch,
go to squarespace.com forward slash
biographics to save 10% off your first
purchase of a website or domain.
Do keep in mind going through that
link helps us keep making these videos.
All right,
let's talk about some killing
shoulder raise.
Family began circulating rumors
that he had gone mad and that he was
experimenting with Alchemy.
Even if this was true,
alchemy was very misunderstood.
This wasn't a form of witchcraft.
It was actually a very early
form of chemistry. Years later.
Other monikers like Queen Elizabeth the
first would hire alchemists as well,
but according to this rumor,
he was taking those outcomist
practices one step too far,
taking them into the coals and that it
actually sold his soul to the devil.
He partnered with an Italian
man named Francois [inaudible].
He was really meant to
also be an alchemist.
Some even say that the two men were in
a forbidden romantic relationship and
that they both attempted to
summon a demon named baron.
They said the baron would be
able to make goals up here.
How to thin app off to trying three
times and failing Francois per last.
He apparently told shoulder ray theirs.
If they wanted to make the spell work,
they would need to be human sacrifice.
As the story goes.
Shoulder Ray Lewis children to his
counsel with the goal of killing them in a
ritualistic sacrifice in the 15th century,
children would walk the streets
alone and go missing all the time.
We now know that young kids should
never walk up city streets unsupervised,
but at that time parents
wanted someone else to blame.
When that child disappeared back then,
it was impossible for people to fathom
that even Catholic priests were actually
Peter Fallacy where responsible for many
of the disappearances for the citizens
of a deeply religious Catholic nation,
it was actually easier for people to
believe that one devil worshiping serial
killing alchemist was responsible for
the deaths of all the missing children in
France.
According to the storage builder,
Ray would bring in young boys to the
console with the promises of making them
his page or his squire on and to have
their son walk with one of the most famous
nights in the country and they wouldn't
think twice about letting their son
leave with a stranger on a horse. The
boy, however, I'd never come back.
The coal claims that he would decapitate
the children collect their heads on
stakes and Oscar's house guests, which
one they thought was the most beautiful.
He agree with Todd of collecting heads
and began sacrificing these children on a
satanic alter,
allowing the rotting bodies to pile up
and sometimes burning the corpses in the
fireplace.
After he was accused of worshiping Satan
and killing children or shoulder ray
and all his servants denied the claims.
His friends also came
forward and testified on his
behalf saying that this was
all a lion, that they never saw
anything at all like that in his castle,
but that testimonies,
they were left out of the trial
after enduring physical torture.
They finally signed confessions to a
story that had been written about that
crimes, the Oms, these signs, confessions.
There was never any physical proof
that any of this actually ever happens.
In 1440 childer ray was convicted
of witchcraft and Mehta.
He was executed on October
the 16th of that year.
The Duke of Brittany gains control over
all of his money and land and divided as
among his family.
The king even gave them permission to
take possession of any former lands that
had been sold to pay for
Joel to raise depths.
The Catholic Church also got a huge
chunk of money from this donation.
Some say that Jill to raise his
body was burned after hanging,
which was the procedure for anyone
accused of witchcraft. However,
the Gutenberg project,
which studies various witchcraft cases
throughout history says that they found
evidence that he was actually
given a Christian burial.
This was kept a secret because
it would prove that the cloud,
she completely made up the accusations
of witchcraft and devil worship.
This story, it was so shocking and
salacious among the French people.
It was hard to believe that anyone could
make up such a story about anyone to
then it felt like they were duped into
trusting a wolf in sheep's clothing.
The story was told over and over again
and it just became a part of French
folklore. The story sends the message
that with enough money and enough power,
they are a stock cracy.
You can get away with anything and that
the common people must seek justice for
inequality.
Hanging shoulder ray became like a
victory for the people and the peasant
classes and many people still believe
to this very day that the story they've
been told is the truth.
While it's true that shoulder
ray confessed to the murders,
it was only after torturing him and
threatening to excommunicate them from
France. They never discovered any
bodies of children on his property,
even if they were burned,
that would still be bone fragments
somewhere that all of the evidence,
it was circumstantial and it would
never hold up in a court of law.
Today in 1992 the New York Times reported
about the possibility of reopening the
case of shoulder re. Many
French historians got very
defensive about the case,
saying that he was truly an awful serial
killer and that it's not possible that
anyone would be falsely accused of
something so horrific. For years,
a woman named Margo Kgb collected nearly
every book that had been published with
information about shoulder rape.
She went as far as to
translate the original trial
documents from Latin and read
all of the biographies in
both French and English.
She even discovered that the transcripts
were also altered after the trauma was
over changing children. Ray's testimony
to sound even more over the top,
adding even more gruesome details to his
supposed confession about slaughtering
children.
Juby wrote her own biography on shoulder
ray and held a public retrial on his
behalf. She proved that if
the same trial happened today,
they would never be enough evidence
to convict him of Metta. For some,
this was enough to efficiently
exonerate him. For others,
they will never be able to let go of
the idea that [inaudible] was one of the
worst serial killers who have lived.
So I hope you found the video interesting.
If you did,
please do give us a thumbs up below and
don't forget to subscribe for brand new
videos twice a week. Also, as I mentioned,
do checkout all sponsors Squarespace.
You'll find a link to them in the
description below, and as always,
thank you for watching.